Do you have suggestions for how to make a schedule that doesn't make you a
tyrant?
I have watched your previous videos,
but I'm struggling to make the week to schedule that it's productive.
Hey,
Joshua,
start by making a weekly schedule that you want.
Really,
like,
imagine that you're designing your schedule so that you can have the life you
want.
Just start with that like,
and be easy on yourself to begin with.
You know,
you'll get better at it.
You can add more responsibilities as you,
as you practice.
So,
so start by just scheduling and a few things that you'd like to do and then load
it up over time.
But remember,
like get,
get your attitude,
right?
I'm using the schedule so that I can have the days and the weeks and the months
that would make my life,
that would optimize my life,
right?
Not so that I should do what I need to get done.
I mean,
obviously that's necessary,
but that's not the right goal.